افادت مراسله الجزيره بالافراج عن الاسئله
الفلسطينيه ماهر يونس بعد انتهاء مده
محكميته بالسجن 40 عاما وكان ماهر وهو من
سكان داخل الخط الاخضر اعتقل بتهمه
المشاركه في قتل جندي سالي
وحكم عليه بالاعدام شنقا ثم تخفيف الحكم
الى السجن المؤبد وفي عام 2012 حددت مده
المؤبد ب 40 عاما يذكر ان السلطات
الاسرائيليه رفضت مرارا وضع ماهر يونس ضمن
الصفقات التبادل
هذه صور مباشره اذا مشاهدينا تاتينا من
داخل بيت الاسير مهليون الصفي عرعره في
داخل الخط الاخضر
والترقب وصول الاسير المحرر الى منزله
سنتابع اذا من المنزل مع مراسله الجزيره
نجوى السمري تبدو جائزه الان في الاستماع
نجوان وانت داخل المنزل اذا الاجواء في
استقبال الاسير وايضا الحديث حول التضييق
الذي يفرض على العائله والاجواء
الاحتفاليه تفضلي
هنا في منزل الاسير المحرر ماهر يونس في
بلده داخل الخط الاخضر هو اقترب كثيرا من
هنا بعد ان تحرر من سجن وهالي كيدار في
النقب وصل قبل قليل الى بلدته توجه مباشره
الى مقبره القريه وزاره والده الذي توفي
عام
وثلاثه والان يصل الى الموقع هنا الى
المنزل الكثير من المهنئين
قالوا الى هنا رغم كل القيود التي وضعتها
الشرطه
الاسرائيليه اذا بالفعل هو وصل الى هنا
ولكن همم يلاقيه في الموقع همم مئات
المهنئين الذي الذين وصلوا الى هذا الى
منزله
وكما تسمعون
هتافات والزغاريد
تنطلق في منزل عائله ماهر يونس الذي سيدخل
الان الى هذا المنزل الذي ولد فيه واعتقل
وكان عمره 25 عاما قبل 40 عاما قدها داخل
الاسر
والان سيدخل الى والدته التي تنتظره منذ
40 عاما وهي هذه اللحظه
وكانه يتحرر الى عصر اخر بعد 40 عاما من
الاسر في المقبره سمعنا الاسير المحرر
ماهر يونس يقول ان الوحده
بين
الفصائل الفلسطينيه هي هديه الشعب
الفلسطيني وقال ايضا انه كان يتامل
ها هو الاسير ماهر يونس يصل الى المنزل
بعد اربعين عاما دام فيه سجون الاحتلال